miss me
[Laughter]
anymore
[Music]
come on
that is
[Music]
how many times
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
what's up foreign
[Laughter]
each other
[Music]
from me
and welcome back to the riddles podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims today
we're joined with a very special guest
yeah again brother Dylan Madden how you
doing my man doing fantastic Brothers
thank you for having me of course the
pleasures are honesty is long overdue uh
we met you back in February in Dubai uh
when we came out to see sartorial
shooter and um honestly
from my personal experience a great guy
just like you to just like the rest of
them uh super super chill guy uh but I
do want to ask so you are people are
asking professor of what
uh so I'm the professor of freelancing
so like what is freelancing freelancing
is basically trading a skill in exchange
for money so like the traditional method
that most people make money from is what
trading their time for money uh the
thing I like about freelancing is you
could essentially take on two three four
or five clients and I'd be working with
them and it's not like okay you're going
to be working 10 hours here uh then this
is going to take 20 hours like you can
come in and as long as you work
efficiently you don't waste your time
you can essentially take on as many
clients as you want and then once you
get to the higher levels of the
freelance and Campus of the real world
then I've got the the money back super
soldier and we've also got the money
back club uh where I go in and I teach
you literally how to build up your own
team because obviously you don't want to
just be the freelancer guy that's out
there like example copywriting there's
web designers and there's many types of
copywriting but any type of school you
can monetize online I teach you how to
do that within the real world and you
don't want to be that guy that's just
sitting there okay I've got to fulfill
for the client work no you want to have
a team around don't you so like you'll
eventually get to a point where you only
work on the things that you genuinely
like and then also you're more of like
uh for lack of better words a manager
like you're making sure that things are
getting done and a mistake that a lot of
people actually make is they think that
they need to literally Outsource every
aspect of the business and then all of a
sudden you're not doing anything that
excites you like if you genuinely enjoy
writing emails or genuinely enjoy doing
the web design that don't Outsource it
like sure bring on somebody that can
help you take home more clients but you
could let's say you don't enjoy doing
Legion and closing clients that's a
perfect thing for you to hire out so I'm
the professor of freelancing in the real
world
all right very nice very nice so let's
say someone's okay free freelancing
sounds interesting I don't know where to
get started what should they do
so this is actually the the perfect way
that I I answer that question is once
you get inside of the freelancing campus
everything is orchestrated by steps so
like example like if you just walk in
it's like whenever you're riding a bike
you can clearly see people are able to
ride bikes but you're going to fall off
and you're gonna oh God I just wiped out
oh oh and eventually you'll get back up
after you follow the steps like example
my grandfather uh he taught me how to
ride the bike he kept me he's like no
Dylan here's what you got to do he
walked me through the steps and then
before long I was riding bikes and I got
a what was it called a BMX bike I was
doing all the tricks that's basically
how the freelancing campus is designed
it's like step one step two step three
step four that way whenever you come
into something brand new it's not like
overwhelming like for example Islam it's
to the the beginner it's kind of
overwhelming at first but then people
such as you guys you walk people through
step by step so once you enter the
freelancing campus I I'll help you pick
your skill I hope you understand why do
I even need a skill I hope you
understand how to put together to offer
how to find clients and I literally just
walk you through every aspect and I've
got various courses that are within that
step oriented format that way it's not
like you just get there and you're like
oh my gosh I've got like 10 different
courses where do I store it no let me
start with step one step two and then
behind that I've also designed something
called the simple steps program where
literally every single day you know
exactly what to do because obviously as
a beginner you're okay why watch all
these videos and I see all these people
asking questions but like what what do I
need to do so I also have the simple
steps so you just go through that you
know how to re okay I need to reach out
to people on social media I need to be
sending x amount of DMs I need to be
doing this I need to be doing that and
part of a new upgrade that should be
dropping in two days from now is every
course of mine is also going to have
action steps on every single video so
instead of you watching the video and
you have to take notes manually you're
going to go through that video it's
going to have exact like the summary
it's gonna have the action steps and
then on top of that I do except on
Saturday and Sunday Monday through
Friday I do nightly amas so every single
night it's called money bag AMA where
you can come on there and ask me
questions live so it's not just some
choreographingly it's 100 live and on
top of that I've also got various chats
because example like if you come in
you're a copywriter you don't care about
learning all these people asking about
web design like you want to learn about
copywriting you won't like to see what
other people are doing so I've designed
various chats for that as well and I
mean that's pretty much the answer bro
all right all right amazing so just to
get out of the way now where can they
find these resources and where they
where can they find you
yeah so I mean the best place to find me
is obviously on Twitter at moneybag
lives however to get inside of the real
world just go type in the join the real
world and you'll go to that uh maybe you
guys want to post it I don't know but
you can uh but yeah just type in join
the real world there's we've got so many
people out there that are sharing the
message what we're doing uh for the real
world that's really the easiest way and
like I don't sell any courses outside of
what I do within the real world so like
for anybody because I've been seeing a
lot of this lately hey bro I I really I
watched this one video of yours can you
please like do you have any courses no I
don't sell courses I don't do coaching I
don't do any of that everything is
inside the real world so courses
coaching gotta join the real world
um
yeah what would you say are the most
profitable copywriting not copywriting
freelancing skills from your experience
today in 2023
I mean the issue that a lot of people
come in is they they're looking for like
the most profitable and that is a good
question but it at the end of the day it
comes down to what are you I'm not gonna
say naturally good at but what example
if you ask me to like okay Dylan the
best way to make money in 2023 is web
design here's what you need to do you've
got to learn coding you've got to learn
this you need to learn like it would
basically just be like banging my head
up against the wall but if you told me
uh get into writing okay cool well
there's like a million different
applications of writing so I always
recommend students start with not what
you're naturally good at because you're
what you're going to be like but I'm not
good at anything yet so like but what
kind of just sits with well with your
mind like on my end any type of web apps
web design graphic design all that type
of stuff I can kind of do it oh I can't
do app development web design and graph
design I can kind of do but it's the
advanced stuffs like that you couldn't
even teach me like it's basically
impossible but anything with writing 100
you can get into but to give the viewer
something like a direction I would
definitely recommend copywriting because
copywriting is a skill that applies to
really anything you're going to be
trying to do uh like I use copywriting
obviously with writing emails I use
copywriting with tweets I use
copywriting whenever I'm making videos
you use copywriting if you're making a
website opt-in form a landing page all
that type of stuff so copywriting is a
good Baseline skill to understand but if
you're not one of those people this just
naturally good at writing
I'm not saying you can't learn it you
definitely could but like I recommend
dabbling the different skills so inside
of the real world I have various
resources built around different skills
so you can kind of dab a little bit and
then once you figure out like okay this
doesn't feel like I'm banging my head up
against the wall I'm going to double
down on that uh but yeah copywriting is
definitely a good one because there's so
many applications like there's email
copywriting you can write sales Pages
you can be a Twitter Ghost Writer
there's even people getting paid writing
descriptions for people on Instagram uh
outside of that video editing
specifically long form uh because that's
a high in demand skill that I've been
seeing lately because everybody can like
example download some kind of AI
upload the video and have like an Alex
romanzi type of video pop out like
within 30 seconds so if you're going to
go down the short form content route as
far as being a video editor for that you
need to get good at being creating
almost like your own style for that
client because a lot of people everybody
I don't know about now but everybody up
to probably a month ago everybody wanted
to have like Alex romantic Style videos
now they're luckily getting away from
that so copywriting and video editing
would definitely be two very very
profitable skills in 2023 because
there's so many different applications
of it
perfect bro perfect
I feel like a lot of the time when it
comes to business the two main things I
hold people back would be one not
knowing what they're wanting into as you
mentioned and as you kind of clarify the
way in which you can figure that out but
two just not really believing that that
stuff is possible not really fathoming
that it is actually doable this business
that you want to create is possible you
can build a team you can build it you
know your own Empire
um they just don't see as a reality even
if they pretend that they do so how do
you get past that how do you really you
know custom make your own reality your
own business
so a huge part of what I do is I
literally brainwash people to believe in
themselves by just bashing into their
face every single day all these people
they're winning example there's this 14
year old kid that I keep talking about
all the time he's 14 years old
he made six thousand dollars as an email
copywriter I had some kid this was what
was this about a night or two ago I was
doing a money back AMA so yeah it was on
Friday and he's like bro I'm 17 and I
really want to get the email copywriting
but I just don't think it's possible and
I went on this I called a money back
rant I went on this money back rant
about are you telling me there's a 14
year old that's smarter than you and can
make more money than you and he was so
riled up so a huge part of that is yes
getting people to believe in themselves
and you have to do it by one like just
telling like talking to him how it is
like I'm not I don't care about your
feelings I'm here to help you make money
here's what you need to do stop
overthinking you should have to keep
like hammering them about it but then
you back that up by as we we talk about
like this custom-made reality showing
your receipts we talked about that in
the War Room showing the receipt so I
literally show them here's this 14 year
old that made six grand as an email
copywriter here's this 23 year old
that's making 10 grand a month here's
this uh what was this he's 24. he's got
a cleaning business he literally took
the stuff I teach people to apply like
the freelance and copywriting all that
type of stuff and turn it to a cleaning
business and now he's just rolling in
the money so a huge part of it yeah
you're 100 correct is believing in
yourself and the big thing that I'm
really
getting people to understand is a lot of
them they think that they join the row
world and really just anything the same
as with religion they just think that
all of a sudden overnight everything's
just going to make sense no it's a
process so don't be so hard on yourself
I understand it's going to take time
whether it takes two weeks whether it
takes a month whether it takes six
months as long as you get to that
outcome why do you care so much and
understanding that and this is just a
affirmation if you want to call it that
that I can't a motto that I tell people
if he can do it so can you like if this
guy is 14 years old if he's can if he
can make six grand a month you can too
whenever I got started I didn't know how
to set up a website I didn't know what I
didn't even know what copywriting was I
just knew that I could get paid to write
for people I didn't know what email
copywriting was it was but I just
believed in myself enough to where I
kept taking one step and the next and
then the next and I started figuring
this stuff out and you also have to
understand that in this world like
obviously God has to ordain it and all
that type of stuff but if you don't act
actually take the time to learn this
whether it's picking a skill it doesn't
even need to be in freelancing it can be
anything who else is going to make make
you the money that you want to make like
nobody has ever in this world that I
know of just walked up to some random
person you know you're really Charming
you're likeable you I can tell you're a
genuine guy let me write a check for
like 10 million dollars like no nobody's
ever done that that I know of yeah so
you have to go out there and do it and
the less you have the less your family
is going to have the less the like your
your wife is going to have the kids Etc
like so you have to go out there and
take the stuff seriously like sure you
can go through your life doubting
yourself and hesitating but your future
kids are going to suffer because I mean
if you look at the data more than likely
you're going to have a wife you're
probably gonna have a kid do you want
your kid not being able to have like
whatever reality it is you want to have
example having to go to these like I
don't know if I could say this on the
podcast but you see what's going on in
the schools in America like if you don't
actually apply yourself you're kid is
going to have to be have that stuff like
forced down their throat unless that it
looks like Christians and Muslims are
coming together to fix that but do you
want your kid to have to face that just
because you're being lazy today no so
get get to work stop doubting yourself
and understand that in time and I say
this all the time experience breeds
confidence the more experience you get
the more confident you're going to be so
even if you doubt yourself now you have
to understand that well it's because you
haven't actually gone out there and done
anything but if you go out there and do
it you follow the simple steps you'll
gain that confidence and you'll you'll
create the custom-made reality like you
were just talking about it's been done
bro I love that you mentioned that of
course God has to ordain it but then we
also have to do the work and this
reminds me of something that the prophet
saws you know he shared with mankind
that there was a man that came to him
and asked should I tie my camel
basically like so it doesn't run away or
should I put my trust in Allah and the
prophet peace be upon him told him you
should tie your camel and put your trust
in Allah so there is a big amount of
work that we have to do and then we have
to put our trust in Allah and today we
have a huge World bro of men and women
that are in one extreme or the other so
they either take everything into their
own hands or they just say you know what
if God wills it I don't have to work I
don't have to lift a finger it's going
to happen so how do you approach that
with your understanding of God and also
Free Will and hard work
so through my upbringing I I saw family
members of mine I won't name drop them
because I know that they want to watch
this podcast uh they would literally sit
around praying and praying and praying
that certain things would be taken care
of and I noticed it would
but it would it's like you don't get
past that like God will always provide
for you take care of you but then I've
also seen the people that there it's all
about them control and they get the
success but then they have this like
mental breakdown or just they're not the
type of person I would want to be or
something like that so like early on I
said thank God I was able to experience
that type of stuff so on my end it's
reminding myself that no matter what
every single day God will provide for me
and he's going to open up the doors he's
going to put me example and podcasts
like this he's going to keep guiding me
step by step putting the right people
into my life like it was totally random
that we we met months ago and I was
having all these thoughts and we sat
down and you guys were answering my
questions in real time I was just like
geez I've literally been Googling this
and I don't think that was just random I
think God put all of us there in that
room together and but at the same time
he's not just going to let you sit over
there on the couch like a lot of the new
age people their Law of Attraction kind
of manifest whatever like you have to
actually go out there and do it so God
will open up the doors for you but you
actually have to go out there and apply
yourself and that's something I remind
myself of all the time like if I feel
because everybody like feels pressure
like the past couple weeks I've been
feeling pressure and everything in my
mind but I was just like this is a part
of the process like God is testing me to
figure out if I'm actually serious about
this and that's something I can
literally track that back to where
whenever I just got started like I I
view taking action as you're literally
proving to God that all these things you
pray for
you're serious about it and not only
that if you want to pray and you want to
go to this next supposed level whatever
that is well you because you're not
there yet that's like proof that you're
not ready for it so you have to become
ready for it the only way to get ready
for it is through taking these actions
getting the right mindsets building the
right Network building the right skills
and you're only going to do that through
actually getting off the couch getting
out there putting your work boots on and
getting to work and yeah sure you might
feel like uh yeah I don't know if this
is gonna work but it's all part of the
process and that's something I've done
ever since I man like 2017 I came back
from California it was like 142 dollars
to my name I had a sheet of paper that
I've written down some different hustles
and I was just like man
where did I go wrong like I was in my
like early to mid 20s I was like man
where did I go wrong like oh man but I
just I was like you know what I'm going
to stick with this Craigslist thing I
know I can make money immediately with
it I don't have to go back to a job yet
and
that week all my bills I was able to pay
for my bills I wasn't making a lot of
money but I was able to pay for my bills
and I just kept doing it doing it and
doing it now here we are years later and
I for the past four or five years been
traveling the world thanks be to God
I've been able to like retire my mom and
just take care of the people around me
I've got a solid team if you would have
told me that like six or seven years ago
I'd be like no bro there's no way like
what you're living in Dubai you're doing
this you're doing that that's crazy but
because I kept praying about it and I
kept applying myself improving myself I
continue becoming that next version of
myself that I had to be to be able to
take handle that pressure the pressure
that I have on a day-to-day basis that I
don't even think about is just like no
yep everything's great if I would have
done that 70 years ago I would have been
like
oh man oh I don't know if I can take
this like so you have to apply yourself
and understand it's going to take as
long as it takes and you're you're going
to acquire those skills and everything
else over time I mean I don't know if
I'm rambling at this point but that to
me is how I make that balance is I've
seen people that just pray and pray and
pray and they get the bare minimum
because God will take care of you if
you've got a good heart but at the same
time the people that have all the
success but they don't have God
it's literally just an empty shell so
you have to find that middle ground
there's an Ayah in the Quran or a verse
in the Quran where Allah says do they
think that they'll say that they believe
and they won't be tested so it's not
about just having the inner game or the
mindset or the belief and then you just
take your hand off the steering wheel
and you just lay back and life will just
unfold to the best of you know what you
would have imagined and there won't be
any tests there won't be any trials and
tribulations we know that's not the case
but I do love the point that you
mentioned that you know you felt that we
were destined to meet that day right so
do you want to go into that like were
you actually going to hang out with
shooter that day when we were coming
over to his house like how did that go
behind the scenes because we only know
when we came for lunch and you were
there so what was the story because we
as Muslims we don't believe anything
happens by coincidence
so him and I were we're going to hang
out a couple days prior to that and then
I got busy then he got busy and he's
like hey bro I've got like a a couple
hours if you want to come over I do have
some guys coming over uh they might want
you on the podcast I'm not sure but yeah
just come over you can eat some steak do
whatever you want and then we'll figure
out from there and I was like oh okay
sounds good and I just came over and I
had no idea who any of you were like
literally whenever they're not knowing
any of you and then like it was just how
open you guys were this how you carry
yourself how open you were how you
carried yourself and then we just got to
talking and I was I wasn't going to say
much at first because I was like ah yeah
uh whatever I I this is stuff I need to
figure out on my own but I just felt
compelled to start talking and then one
thing led to another and we all started
having good conversations and the
conversation sort of naturally leading
towards questions that I'd had because
like I I was a Christian I still I
consider myself one still but at the
same time I because I see my friends
like example Andrew Tate then Jules Etc
I keep all my friends around me not all
of them but quite a few of them are
beginning to revert not convert revert
uh back to Islam and or to Islam so I
just want to I don't want to be that guy
that's like ignorant and doesn't have
any idea of what they're talking about
so I'd like to have a nice conversation
and as I started learning more about it
I was like
and this is like so logical like it's it
answers some of the questions I've had
not all of them but some of the
questions I've had I like how logical it
is and like even though I've considered
myself a Christian for years I this this
might be sinful to the Christians that
are watching but like I've never
actually like I don't really play pray
in Jesus name I've always just had a
conversation between me and God
so and it's not I don't know like I I do
believe in Jesus still but at the same
time
I was just like that it was a human and
so it was like all these little
questions that were going around my mind
and we all sat down we just had a
conversation about it and I ended up
walking away with a sense of peace and
then shortly after that yeah I don't
know if it was a week two weeks after
that I don't know but I ended up getting
on the dean show and then he gave me
some further uh resources that I could
go through and it was just one thing
after another and just kept expanding my
mind so yeah that was how it happened
and how was your experience when we all
went to the mosque together was that
your first time or was that did you go
with shooter before that
so I'd never been to the mosque with him
before but I'd actually been to the
mosque probably two or three times
previously and I it was one of those
things I wasn't talking about I had a
friend of mine who visited from Canada
and I'm trying to remember it's the
evening prayers like the last prayer of
the day Isha no what is it
Sunset Isha is is at night yeah yeah
sure that was the one that we went to
then he was like hey bro like I was
literally it was probably like 10
minutes from here uh the mosque was
right next to the hotel and he was like
hey bro I'm about to go to the mosque
after that if you want to grab something
to eat and I was like oh yeah sure and
I'd always wanted to go to a mosque but
I always felt like
I don't want to be that one guy that's
in there doesn't know what to do so I'm
out of respect I'm just not going to go
I was like hey is it cool if I go with
you he's like yeah man come on let's go
let's go and it was right literally
right next to my uh apartment or the
hotel that I was staying at at the time
and so we ended up going to that but the
experience of you guys was awesome
because like all of you were you were
able you're just the way you were
talking about it it made it more real it
wasn't just me going in and just looking
to my left to writing copy whatever
everybody else is doing you're actually
explaining it and we had like a really
really good conversation and it just it
animated it made it more real in my mind
so I I really enjoyed it yeah that was
probably my third or fourth time going
to the Moscow at that point
well well honestly that's beautiful and
shout out to uh to the Warner may Allah
bless them he was there with us as well
I don't think he's been mentioned yet
but uh definitely a a tank of a guy may
I love lesson both physically and andawa
yeah for sure he's actually I'd seen him
before quite a few times oh yeah
whenever I walked in also that was like
one of the first things that I noticed
was like this like eight foot tall guy I
was like I swear I've seen him before
but I'm not that guy that's like hey do
you do you have an Instagram you have a
YouTube I don't do that so I got to know
him and then I was like I
pretty sure I've watched several videos
and then he told me his name and I I
Googled it right you did it on YouTube I
was like oh snap that's that guy so it
was just crazy how that whole thing
happened and then here we are months
later having a podcast together yeah you
had no idea what was gonna happen when
you don't know with Jewel that day oh no
not at all I knew that there's going to
be some kind of podcast thing that I
wasn't really sure so I had no idea who
you guys were or I didn't even know the
Warner was there I didn't know the
Warner at the time either so yeah and I
don't honestly I don't think any of us
knew what was gonna happen we recorded
like we had one of the best
conversations one of the best
experiences we met you uh the war in the
camera actually that was the first time
we met the Warner as well by the way
that's a trip to Dubai yeah yeah I only
met in person a few days before I met
you and then you know we did like the
best we recorded like the best podcast
um I think on the channel to this day so
far so that day was honestly a blessing
from God but a lot of people are asking
me in the chat are you a Muslim Dylan
not yet not yet as far as I haven't
taken the shahada or anything like that
I mean all my friends around me keep
saying that I already am I just haven't
accepted it yet and times catching up uh
so I'm on the path I'm on the path and
I've always been like example and I
think I told you guys the story in
person I was in like middle school and I
was reading the Quran they had one in my
library and the librarian took it from
me it was like weirded me out because I
was sitting there reading it and I was
like oh wow
okay because like growing up especially
in America like as a white American
especially like you're just like I don't
know if I should read this but I was
reading it I was like oh wow this is
interesting she just came and took it
from me and that that was basically the
end of me looking into it but because I
was probably like 12 years old 13 years
old something like that uh so but then
since what was it when I was in Couture
because I lived at Qatar for about a
year I obviously every person I was
friends with there was a local there uh
Catherines they're obviously all Muslims
so we were we would have conversations
about and that started opening my mind
up it was probably like 20 21 I want to
say so that since then I've kind of been
studying into it and then obviously once
Andrew take reverted and then uh Jewels
Etc obviously that further Amplified my
interest in it so yeah
all right that's I I so now I have I
have I think what's an important
question we see how some Muslims let me
get the camera some Muslims
um you know interact with Andrew Tate
and respond to some of the things he
says and does do you ever feel like
there is a bit of a pushback against the
Muslim Community or do you ever feel
like maybe there's a little hostility on
with some of them does that ever push
you away
yeah that actually the thing that
started attracting me to Islam is I was
like man it's like everybody's like this
it's like this almost like a Brotherhood
or something like everybody supports
each other everybody's for each other
yeah and then I saw my friend a revert
and I've seen so many people join Islam
and I'm not whether like they're 100
real I don't know but I've seen videos
and pictures of all these kids that you
would never think would or become a
Muslim and they've reverted to Islam
they started studying and I was like wow
the exhaustvits added to that excitement
but then I've seen more and more people
and it's I would say overall it's more
so positive but it has kind of been
pushing me away because I'm like wait a
second it's like people are example
there's some people complaining the
other day about how he took a picture
from reading the Quran laying down but
then somebody else posted
everybody that's complaining about this
you need to go read your own book like
if you literally look at them it says
and I've got it right here uh if a
person recites the Quran while he is
standing and correct me if this is not
in the Quran but if the person recites
the Quran while he is standing lying on
his bed or in other positions is
permissible and is rewarded so it's like
all these different things like that
it's so it's kind of pushed me back to
be honest not completely obviously but
the thing that really attracted me to
Islam was how United everybody was it
was like this driving force against
shaytan in this in this world because
ever in this world even with Christians
it's like okay this is my church oh yeah
we don't talk to them and I'm not saying
that's how it is for everybody that's
just been my personal experience this is
my church that's all I care about but
then whenever I saw Islam it was like it
was like the the world is like your
friend the world every single Muslim out
there you're United and so that's
something I would like to I guess
re-experience and it's for all these
people that are watching this and
they're judging Andrew he literally just
reverted I don't know how long it's been
but like he's been very supportive Islam
for a while now like at least a couple
years he's been talking about it and
then he's reverted and you have to
understand like if you and I I use this
example this might not be the best
example but imagine you eat McDonald's
every single day you don't eat healthy
food you just drink soda you never work
out and then you decide to do
start eating healthy food you start
drinking water you start working out
you're going to slip up from time to
time because you've spent most of your
life in this one type of way so on
Andrew's side he literally spent his his
life like most of his life at the at a
height of human experience and most
people won't and even he has decided to
come to Islam and use that as his
driving force he's reading the Quran all
the time he'll even send me random uh
like what do you call them scriptures
he's actively studying he's been he's
very supportive and like he literally
just officially reverted so like guys
have calmed out like he's spent most of
his life living type of way and he's put
a lot of that away like example back in
December uh for his birthday it was like
early December we went to a club he
refused to drink like people were like
oh that's just for the video I was there
you can't tell me what I saw like he
refused to drink he started like
changing his life all the way back to
early early December he was changing the
way he did things the way he spoke the
way he carried himself in certain things
uh like obviously the core of the man is
the same but you know what I mean like
the more Haram type of stuff he started
pushing that away more and more and he
stood out there in the sun he would have
the weights next to him he'd be going
like that put them down pick up the
Quran and read and that was actually the
Quran he ended up giving me right before
he or temporarily left so it's like he's
act he's actively studying he's actively
bringing positivity to the world and
then now he's empowered by Islam and
that was something that really really
inspired me uh so I was like man this is
what the world needs because everybody's
so scattered now
left versus right uh oh yeah it's
completely okay for kids to do certain
things to their bodies it's permanent
but then Islam comes in and it's just
this firm like no you are not doing that
that's that's Haram here's what you need
to do here's how you're going to guide
your day-to-day life here's this it just
makes everything make sense so yeah bro
it was it seeing how some of the Muslims
and I I once again I'd say overall it's
mostly positive because the people that
actually read the Quran they're not
going to come after him like that but
those random people on Twitter and I'm
sure there's even YouTube channels that
are coming at him it's it's nonsense it
really is yeah absolutely and forgive me
if I go on a bit of a rant here
um firstly so that what you read is
actually it's a quote of of a scholar or
maybe the opinions of Scholars based on
the Quran so they read the Quran there
is a verse in the Quran Allah he talks
about people who remember Allah standing
or sitting or lying or laying on their
sides you know so it's completely
permissible and the scholars have a lot
about it so as Layman you don't have a
person in the world who can go against
what a scholar is saying based on
evidence with their their low
understanding of what Islam is and I
think for the most part people don't
even understand what's wrong with it
people don't they can't even agree on
what's wrong is it that he's lying down
is it because he's wearing shorts they
don't they have literally no idea you
know and there's and on top of that
these people are so ignorant that they
can't even see he's not even reading the
Quran he's reading an English
translation of the Quran right so the
exact verbatim Holy Scripture word for
word is not there it's an English
translation so it doesn't even have the
same exact level as the actual Quran so
these people don't know what they're
talking about but Islam is like like
it's like a perfect car you know you can
still have the idiot that crashes it you
know you can have the best car the most
perfect car you're still gonna have the
who can't drive and you know slams
it to the wall so Islam in the Quran it
says
it says indeed the Believers are
brothers so make peace with your
brothers and then it goes on and says
and remember Allah if you want to be the
ones who receive his mercy so if you are
really a Believer you will love the
other uh Believers like your brother
like your sister even if you have
disagreements with them that is the
essence of Brotherhood in Islam what we
also know is that the prophet peace be
upon him he prophesized that the main
test that the whole Muslim Nation would
be given is sectarianism and division so
you will find a select few people who
are just looking for any fault of
someone they don't like to hammer at
home and unfortunately this I think gets
Amplified by a lot of non-muslims haters
of Islam oh look at these Muslims look
what they're saying look what they're
doing you know yeah and online you don't
really know who actually is a Muslim and
who's 100 and I don't just mean who
claims to be Muslim there are some
people who say they're Muslim and we
call them Hypocrites and Islam it's
actually a term people who say they're
Muslim but in their heart they have no
belief at all you know they existed at
the time of the Prophet peace be upon
them they exist today we don't go out
and say you're hypocrite you're
hypocrite this not but they do exist and
it's something Muslims need to be
mindful of so at the end of the day all
Muslims need to come together that we
worship of one God and we have one
Prophet The Prophet Muhammad that we
follow and you know love each other and
love for each other but we love for
ourselves as the prophet said
100 bro I can't even add to that that
was that was beautifully put I apologize
if I rant it a little bit it's just
something that I'm very passionate about
uh personally so I love the passion I
appreciate it I appreciate it so on on
this topic uh I I have you watched
Patrick but David podcast with Andrew
Tate
yeah I watched almost all of it and I I
watched the one with Tristan as well
yeah all right I'm still trying to get
through both of them I started both um
the MJ one's like four hours long so
that's I'm trying to watch I'm doing
work and stuff but I want to focus and I
can't multitask so it's a bit difficult
for me but
um there was a similar issue there where
he said some things and some Muslims
just completely you know took as an
opportunity to go at him
um did he see that situation unfold what
are your thoughts on that yeah so I'm
assuming you're talking about the
segment where he's talked about it's
okay for what was it a Muslim man to
marry a Christian woman or something
there was one of those I saw a ton of
people hating on him for that and I
guess my response to that and obviously
I'm not speaking for him that's just my
personal opinion is oh yo let's go
brother
[Music]
my personal opinion on that would be
like once again he just reverted so it's
like yes maybe to a non-believer it
would make sense like oh yeah I can be
example I've got a A friend of mine from
way back in the day he literally was
Pagan like I didn't even know those
people existed but he's literally pagan
and his wife was Christian
so like for most people outside of Islam
that I guess that's just a normal thing
so you have to instead what I would
recommend and I'm not Muslim so I'm not
speaking for Muslims is like no this is
not correct here's where you should
check this out inside the Quran here's
what the prophet peace be upon Him says
that's what I would recommend but so
yeah I was seeing that and then yeah I
saw some other people like hating on
various things he said in it but once
again guys like he's brand new to Islam
and he's doing a lot of positivity and
and I'm not like literally he's doing
probably doing more positive stuff for
Islam than all those people combine that
are hating on it he's bringing a light
on to Islam and normalizing it in the
minds of a lot of people in the UK in
America and he's getting a conversation
started he's almost making it I don't
want to say making it cool but like
there's still some of that there's
remnants of that westernized like
propaganda of Islam still remaining but
then they're seeing this guy named
Andrew Tate and easily talking he's
talking positively about it he's reading
the Quran he's doing all these things
and that that in the mind of the youth
they're like wait a second maybe all the
stuff that I was Psy Optical to
believing isn't actually true maybe I
should actually go and buy a Quran and
look into it like I get DMS all the time
I hardly check my DMs on social media
but I get DMS all the time and it's like
people hey Dylan I just picked up my
first Quran uh you inspired me whenever
you told me how Andrew gave you one so
it's like all this type of stuff is
causing a ripple effect and he's
creating he's bringing more people to
Islam than all these people combined
that are trying to act as if they no you
should not be doing this oh here's what
no just be positive about it that's
what's going to attract even more people
to Islam is like wow all these people
they're not sitting there like saying no
you're not supposed to do this they're
saying yeah you probably shouldn't do
this here's what you should check out
inside of the Quran and they're being
more positive about it you know yeah
yeah 100 so you remember when you
mentioned that you have never really
prayed to Jesus you've prayed to God or
as a lot of Christians say the father
how do you deal with a lot of I guess
ideological differences from let's say
Christians or Catholics around you when
they're like why are you not praying to
Jesus
so to be honest you guys are the first
people I've ever told that to I've never
that's been something I it was just a
personal thing so this is like the first
time I've actually said that uh so yeah
like example like I've had people that
are Catholic have tried to get me to
come to their church I it's always
seemed and I don't mean to be
disrespectful but it's always seemed
like they're
idolatryally talk about Saints and they
pray to Saints and they do Hail Mary and
all this like that never really felt
like good to me like I was like uh no I
feel like I should only be talking to
God and I also didn't like the way they
portrayed Jesus it was always this frail
white guy by the way guys Jesus wasn't
white he literally was in the Middle
East probably a tan skinned dark care so
I'm just putting that out there it'll be
this fro white guy just over across I
was like bleeding as well like I went to
this Catholic Church one time it was uh
what was this someone sometime in Europe
and it was literally just this like guy
with blood coming out of sans I was like
that you should not be pushing that out
there so to answer your question though
it's just one of those things I never
really spoke about to people because I
used to be that kid in like youth class
where I would be debating the adults
about what I or no that's actually
that's not correct this is what it says
in the Bible I used to be that guy so I
was used to being like disagreeable
about the Bible and about God and about
Jesus uh but yeah I've I've I'd say for
the last like probably eight to ten
years I've just
I don't know it just it didn't it didn't
feel wrong but it didn't feel right so I
just would always talk to my heavenly
father literally what I say is my
heavenly father and I I talk to him I
pray to him I'm grateful all that type
of stuff and I just have never I
probably have said in Jesus Christ's
name amen I said it maybe a handful of
times in the past like eight to ten
years but it just never I'm not really I
wasn't really sure about it so yeah bro
that's my answer and if Jesus Islam as
we say in Arabic if he himself prayed to
the father then why don't we just follow
the religion of Jesus but not the
religion about Jesus this has always
been something that stood out to me now
that's a really good point because he
literally would go away from the
disciples even in the Bible it says this
he would go he would leave the disciples
and go off to be alone and he would he
would pray to God
so it's like why don't we just follow
whatever that was kind of my logic back
in the day was like well I'm just going
to talk to the heavenly father
so yeah in following as far as I I could
go I don't want to go down rabbit holes
I mean we can but I I do believe that
Christianity has been used almost as
like a control mechanism like you can go
down a lot of different rabbit holes and
they kind of they because of what was
going on in the world at that time
they they kind of used it to the example
like the Roman Empire is falling and
they
have you heard of Borgia this was many
years after the Roman Empire film
literally Jesus looks like that Borgia
guy and I've even heard like Charlemagne
uh King Charlemagne or Emperor Charlotte
mainly they even made Jesus In His Image
I mean there's all these weird things
like that that ever since I was like a
kid
I I was reading into that stuff and I
was like
this doesn't sit well with me and then
you hear about like the Council of
nicaea but then there's other books of
the Bible like The Book of Enoch and all
these other books of the Bible that they
didn't allow into the official Bible
they sat down and this is what's going
to happen this is what we believe and
then they would go the priests would go
off and continue preaching whatever
their version of Christianity was and
they'd convene another Council and okay
now we've got to talk about this and
it's I I it didn't feel organic the way
everything kind of transpired it seemed
more so about power if you want to call
it that whatever what would you say to
that
yeah I would say definitely a power had
a big big role in the um in the
development of it if you look at what
Constantine did so Constantine accepted
Christianity and and I think uh the year
312 or 313. yeah um and then 325 he was
like okay listen it's been a decade plus
no one can agree on what Christianity is
there are so many different
denominations different beliefs about
Jesus no one could really agree that's
why he called 300 plus or something like
that theologians and church fathers to
come together in nicaea and to vote and
hash everything out there is that you
guys are going to settle this today and
then I'm gonna rule the Empire based on
whatever you guys decide so they all got
together and then they debated and then
they came to the Nic and Trinity and all
these other things Matthew Mark Luke and
John
um because before that they had like 30
plus gospels Gospel of Peter Gospel of
Mary Gospel of Thomas infancy gospel
Thomas infancy Gospel of Barnabas all
these different things
so no one really knew exactly what Jesus
believed or what he said or what he
preached but Constantine needed to rule
using that religion so he made them
decide and then he ruled based on that
and then he essentially forced people to
accept it they they he basically
destroyed any other scripture that was
there if it's not Mark Matthew Luke and
John it's gone so yeah
yeah that's how we lived and then they
added in the back of the Bible that like
that fear aspect of if you change this
book all the like plagues and everything
from revelation will be yeah even that
as a kid I remember reading that and I
was like ah just I don't like that
either like so many things just didn't
sit well with me over the years but I I
you kind of especially whenever you're
brought up as a Christian you're like
okay that's just how it is Blind Faith
I'm gonna keep talking about it uh so
but yeah I mean there's so many things
that and I'm not well versed enough on
it but there's so many things throughout
the years that I would start reading
about the Bible that I would just be
like uh
not sure okay that's just how it is
maybe it's just maybe it's the devil
telling me this so I'm just I'm not I'm
just the devil trying to get me off the
path I'm just gonna keep reading oh uh I
don't know about that too
and I think that's happened with a lot
of Christians over the years and I also
believe that's why so many people are
opening themselves up to Islam because
the world is getting to the point I do
live in a bubble I will say that so like
I I see reality within my bubble but it
does seem that the world is getting to
the point where people are getting tired
of this all this wokeness uh like people
trying to shove different ideas down
their kids their minds they're
normalizing all this stuff that's
literally going to lead to depopulation
in a bad way uh like it's just so many
things out there and people are fine
they're looking for something that they
can grab onto and that like I was
telling earlier that was something that
kind of attracted me to Islam is
obviously it's one of the only things
that's they're standing firm like with
Christians example
there I can't remember the name of the
pastor the Church of England he stood up
and basically said like spoke out
against gay marriage they kicked him out
of course and they're anybody and that's
a Christian that speaks up and they're
like no this is what the Bible says
they get kicked out
but then they're like no this is not
happening this is what the Quran says
and everybody just respects it so it in
my mind it's almost like there's more
power behind that if you know what I
mean so with Christianity it's
they say one thing but then oh you know
nah okay and then boom they get kicked
out then with Islam they're very firm
they stick to it and people I'm not like
obviously there's definitely been
discrimination against Islam over the
years but yeah as the world is now
people are almost scared to counter
Islam uh because why is that you could
say it's because of a law but I'm just
I'm just putting that out there
honestly bro I feel like any religion
where you have a lot of idolatry or
polytheism it gets watered down to an
extent because with Islam people almost
right away think of God Allah the one
true creator with other religions kind
of like you have this then you have
little saints you have Idols you have
things that you can hold in your hand
and kick around like how do you how do
you respect something like that well I
do I do want to you know I have a
question for oh no first of all about
and uh you as a revert do you think you
had the relationship when you would pray
would you pray to God or did you
sometimes pray to Jesus
no I just pray to God
interesting yeah same as you bro just
pretty good I thought it was so weird in
the these people wanted me to pray to a
man
yeah
hmm
I remember when I went to the church and
it was this was later in life I was
gonna
try to take it seriously the whole
Christianity thing
and I was gonna go to do the baptism
I remember I was
the lady she would grab people and then
she would say oh repeat after me and the
cheese is
stuff about it Jesus Is God and that
he's my savior and then she would dunk
you in the water and that would be it
you know it'd be good like it's game
time right
I don't know if she got to me she said
repeat after me and she's like she said
Jesus Is God and I ended up saying God
is God
she gave me the dirtiest look and then
she put me on the water and usually she
was putting people in the water for a
few seconds she held me under the water
for at least like five ten seconds oh
gosh yeah I saw that I this is what it
is
um to answer your question from before
uh and by the way Angel she was trying
to get any you know any any bad off you
she thought holding you down that long
maybe it would all dissipate down there
or something you came out with the same
man and then later you came out a Muslim
um but yeah so on what you're saying
before I think it's I think it's about
culture to be honest and I think a part
of it is their own liberalism working
against them because they're like if
you're this phobic or that phobic you
know you're a horrible person well there
is islamophobia that exists and that
didn't really come from Muslims it came
from their own world culture that's
that's not something Muslims really a
term they use to be honest in their own
lands it came from the West so now
they're scared of being islamophobic so
they don't want to criticize Islam and
Muslims because they have been
persecuted all over the world and I'd
say another aspect of it is Muslims are
hard to deal with you know you if you
come out Islam you will receive not just
like like threats or anything crazy like
that I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about uh backlash academic
refutations like Muslims will not let
you breathe they will refute your entire
existence and you have to respond to all
this or just sit there and accept it and
most people don't want to deal with that
um and you you see the people that do
deal with it they become very bitter to
be honest so Muslims are hard to do with
alhamdulillah
yeah I wonder if Christianity will ever
get to that point uh because like I
still know plenty of actually actual
good Christians they they don't believe
in idolatry outside of yeah they do
great to Jesus
but they're not and they are firm but
it's like within their own personal
relationships you don't really see many
Christians uniting together like this is
what this is what's happening I I don't
you don't see it you don't see it like
there's so many different denominations
of like I think there's Shia and what's
the other
Sunni yeah so there's only two different
denominations of Islam right yeah and
one is like 95 of Muslims other ones
like a vast minority oh wow and then
Christianity they've got like 30
different denominations and like it's
it's insane uh so maybe Christianity
will start getting firm but that's one
of the the things that I look forward to
in the coming like couple years with
Islam is how more and more they're
staying they're coming together and they
understand social media like the two
things I respect a lot about Muslims is
you guys like are some of the best
Debaters I've ever seen like every
single Muslim person I see on YouTube
like
some of the best Debaters ever like you
know the Quran you even understand the
Bible and then Christians
[Music]
maybe like one per one Christian I've
seen I don't even know his name he's
actually a solid debater he's debated a
a big scholar of Islam and I can't
remember this like he's passed since
then uh
you want Jimmy
what's that there was a Christian
scholar I Believe Jimmy who did me I
believe so I'm gonna do that yeah
so like if more Christians had that I I
believe that more more people be I guess
brought to Christianity but they didn't
film like the two things I respected
about Islam is you're you actually know
what you're talking about and you can
back it up when like from what they are
what their Source says which would be
the Bible you could back it up with the
Quran and then also a massive strength
that you guys have is you understand the
modern era social media you understand
how to put together content and like I I
haven't really seen that from Christians
and that's another reason why you guys
are going to continue dominating the
social media side and people are going
to be like you're going to force people
to get out of this woke mentality like
because you you can't escape like if you
guys keep putting out the content you're
putting out on Twitter on YouTube on
Instagram
like you were saying earlier Romney like
you're going to make them actually Billy
oh we've actually got a list of what
they're saying because you're just going
to keep putting the hammering the
pressure in and I believe that's really
going to wake a lot of people up I've
even seen on social media like
Christians are starting to unite with
Muslims that are standing up for their
own kids really no we don't want this
type of thing being taught to our kids
and now even Christians are joining
hands with Muslims I just saw that
earlier today on Twitter so that's the
if you what you guys just keep hammering
that in it's going to be beautiful like
it gives me hope for the the Next
Generation yes I mean it's it's crazy to
some people that Islam would be the hope
that they need you know Islam is the uh
the the Savior for their Western issues
but what you said is actually very
profound and the reason is because Allah
he says in the Quran let basically the
Muslims and the people of the book come
to terms that they worship one God and
on the surface level with a western
understanding of worship people are
going to think okay you pray to God I
pray to God okay we're you know let's
the unite on that at least Worship in
Islam is not just who you pray to it's
who you obey where your governance comes
from where your morality comes from
what's wrong what's right what you stand
for what you stand against all that
stuff falls under worship because God
dictates all that for us so this is a
prime time to really read that verse and
understand people of the book Jews and
Christians should come together with
Muslims that they worship and Obey one
God and we're not going to give in to
this woke liberal mindset and let our
kids think they're a unicorn or
something we're going to worship God
obey what he says his Commandments and
his way of life and push that onto the
non-believers the the non-muslims the
non-christians the non-jews the atheists
the people with no morality trying to
enforce their way on life onto US no
Allah gave us away
if you don't want to live it you don't
have to live it if you want to be
punished off your life you can go for it
myself my family my brothers my sisters
my kids they're gonna wait live in the
way of God
they're gonna be chills I love that
it's all in the Quran man it's honestly
like any genuinely any good point I've
ever made about Islam came from the the
Quran or the prophet peace be upon him I
think that's why Muslims are so powerful
by the way because they have the
resource they need
you know I actually have a question this
I don't want to take off like golf on a
tangent but
on one of your other episodes you were
talking about we talked about this
privately a little bit but this just for
all the viewers if you don't understand
uh Arabic
but you pray to God and let's say you
never learn act like much Arabic at all
but you consider yourself a Muslim what
happens to you in the afterlife like are
you gonna be judged harshly like what
what's the the truth behind that well
first and foremost when it comes to
anyone their situation is specific in
particular if you have a person who is a
Muslim for 30 years and never tried to
learn you don't have to learn Arabic by
the way you just have to learn certain
words to be able to recite what you need
to in prayer it's maybe less than 100
words yeah it's really not a lot
um and then that's the same words you
repeat for every prayer so it doesn't
take a lot some people learn it in a day
some people learn in a week some people
learn it a month so if you go 30 years
of being a Muslim and never learning it
that if there's a deeper issue that how
committed were you really to the
religion that makes sense yeah but if
you're Muslim for a day and then Allah
takes your soul you know obviously Allah
is not going to be like oh you didn't
learn how to do this you died in the
state of Islam you know what happens
when you stop the slum all your sins of
the past get forgiven and all you keep
all your good deeds so you're like a
newborn baby with a clean slate except
you have any goodies you've done in the
past and if you die a day later you've
you've died honestly a very Noble death
I'd say because you have such a pure
slate so Allah is the most forgiving and
merciful I don't think people should go
into you know the discussion with this
this worry so okay awesome yeah I wanted
to ask that question that's basically
the only questions I had about it but uh
yeah I didn't want to go from the
tangent yeah no worries I'm actually I
was going to ask you because I think
we're gonna have to wrap up within 20 30
minutes or so okay if you have any
questions about Islam you know please
feel free to ask
I said no I'm pretty much good brother I
I've been reading and then obviously
you've opened up your your messages so
if I ever have a question I'll send you
a text message and you give me like a
very profound response I'm like okay
I'll think about it so and that's
basically it at the moment
all right all right perfect question for
you bro
what's going on okay first off how you
doing you're looking real good today man
thank you brother so
have you heard of the time
when Jesus
peace be upon him he disappears
for x amount of time I don't remember
the exact time frame and he comes back
with the Revelation and with
basically the the gospel
have you heard of this
not not that I'm aware of no okay look
into it there is a specific time frame
that Jesus he is he disappears he grows
away and then he comes back and now he
is God
supposedly stop further really yeah yeah
so this I want you to look into it I
want you to ask
as many people about it as possible
because when I found this
I remember I asked someone that was a
very devout Christian
and they told me that why does it matter
what does it matter what happened during
this time
and I was like what like this is the
time where he came back and now he has
everything now he's like yo this is what
it is like this is how we're gonna be
saved this is how we're gonna
do things now
so to say that something like that
doesn't matter
and then I went on to keep looking for
and there's no information anywhere and
any person that I asked I was devout
they couldn't give me an answer on this
it speaks volumes so I want you when you
get the chance just do some research on
the and really reflect on it because
if we were to figure out what he did
during this time
I think that could provide
tons of insight tons of gems of wisdom
that we can apply to our lives to be
better people
yeah
that's crazy yeah so it was in Islam
Jesus's like a very respected like
Prophet correct and he's going to come
back in the end times and basically the
Judgment Day is gonna he's gonna kill
the Antichrist or defeat the Antichrist
effectively yeah yeah okay
um
and then in Islam
he didn't like from what you believe he
didn't actually get crucified like what
what happened after that yeah
oh you got taken up to heaven if I
remember correctly okay yeah so in Islam
Allah says they did not kill him when
nor did they crucify him but it was made
to appear that way so the historical
record showing that Jesus was crucified
is actually contrary to popular belief
not something that Muslims struggle to
deal with because the verse itself says
people believe that he was so the
historical records which come from
people are going to say whatever they
believed you know they say that history
is written from the the perspective of
the Victor right whoever won the war
they get to say whatever they want about
it it's very similar here
so
um we don't really struggle with that
but there's actually evidence I would
say from the Bible to prove this and if
you allow me to go on a little bit of a
rant I want to explain it I bro we have
we have we have a lot of evidence even
from the Bible so if you read Psalm 91
and anyone can open this up I did it on
a podcast with Dr Ali atai recently uh
Psalm 91 speaks about a man who will
glorify and praise God so God will
always also like Praise Him and God will
protect him
God will keep him safe he will triumph
over The Serpent and the lion and you
know God will protect him from any harm
no harm it says will come near his tent
and it says
um a God will send his angels concerning
him so that his foot will not strike the
ground that's in the Old Testament the
last word in that whole passage Psalm 91
is uh Yeshua which is Jesus name which
means salvation to be saved right and
then if you go to Matthew I think
book five or four or five you'll see
that Jesus is taken up to the high point
by Satan and Satan's like listen it says
in the book about you and he quotes
psalm 91.
uh basically God will send his angels
concerning you so your foot will not
strike the ground it will not strike the
rock so jump off this High Point and God
will save you and Jesus says it is also
written do not test your lord
so Jesus affirmed Psalm 91 is about him
but what does it say no harm will come
near his tent God will give him a long
life God will protect him and save him
and God will send his angels concerning
him
what is the Christian conception of what
happened to Jesus
he was stripped naked by the authorities
he was beaten he was born across he was
murdered up there he died up there and
according to Luke he cried out God why
have you forsaken me
but in that same New Testament in the
Book of Matthew it's confirmed that God
will save Jesus and so on and so forth
so where is this discrepancy how does
this discrepancy exist and then you have
the Quran that comes later and it says
they didn't kill him they didn't crucify
him God save them God sent his angels to
lift them up to heaven literally exactly
what Psalm 91 is saying
that is when I found out that I bro my
head exploded when I when I learned that
that's what I feel like is happening to
me right now that's insane I'm gonna
have to go read that yeah I'll send you
everything afterwards don't worry oh
thank you brother of course of course so
yeah
this guy
I mean yeah in all all jokes aside when
you mentioned earlier that
when Romney asked you the same question
that angel just asked you that are you
Muslim are you ready to be Muslim you
mentioned that not yet but I'm on the
path so can you go into that because I
remember when I was watching this
podcast with Andrew Tate on fresh and
fit this was months before he was Muslim
maybe even a year plus and he said that
if I had to bet on one religion like I'm
gonna bet on the stock market it would
have to be a sum and he wasn't a Muslim
but he would bet on it so
are you kind of viewing it as that where
it's like you inevitably see yourself
the more research that you do that you
become Muslim and it's only a matter of
time and if so what are some of the
things that are kind of obstacles
holding you back and getting you a
little bit overstimulated when you think
about it
I mean I'm I tend to be more of a
logical person and logically Islam makes
the most sense to me uh because I've had
I've I was born and raised a Christian
but I always had questions about it and
I would always go go away and then I'll
come back go away come back and
eventually I was like okay Dylan you
keep coming back to Christianity just
you're a Christian
uh but there's always in the back of my
mind there's been certain issues and
there's questions I should say and
I the thing that I I guess is holding me
back from fully making that switch
because I I've essentially I've the dean
show actually walks me through and you
guys walk me through whenever we're
hanging out do you believe this do you
believe this do you believe this do you
believe it was like yes yes yes yes yes
yes so you're a Muslim the biggest thing
for me is
still not getting past that
Jesus thing that the Jesus thing is
really the only that's the last straw
that's holding me back is I because I've
been brought up like my family uh my
friends all everybody believes in Jesus
and I went to church I did all of that
that's still the one the last thing and
actually Robbie you're telling me what
you just said and then obviously I'm
gonna have to go read the other the I
don't know what Bible verse uh what you
were just talking about like how he just
went off and then he came back I don't
I'll find that but like those two
different things it's kind of further
answering that question that I've had
what's profound bro is like once you
actually understand who is Jesus was you
realize that it's because of your love
for Jesus that you will want to be
Muslim because if you really love Jesus
then you wouldn't be a Christian and
this is a loaded statement which a lot
of people viewing they're gonna be like
what do you mean if you really love
Jesus you want to be Christian yeah
Muslims don't disbelieve in Jesus matter
of fact we believe in everything that
Jesus believed even more than Christians
we hold them to such a high regard that
we don't even depict them bro we don't
sculpt them we don't we don't try to
recreate or or you know make a model of
something so holy like a prophet of God
you get me blood I don't mean do you
have anything you want to add to that
yeah I think that's a great point and on
top of that I mean just look at the the
fundamentals of Christianity and the
fundamentals of Islam and I don't mean
oh one is basic one is complex I mean
Christian like Scholars or let's say New
Testament Scholars historians they
debate very fundamental things who was
the founder of Christianity was it Jesus
or was it Paul that's a modern debate
what did Jesus actually say did he
really claim to be God did he even exist
or not people are really still debating
that what he said whether he existed or
not if he claimed to be God was he just
the prophet was he not a prophet was
Messiah what did people believe about
Jesus did the disciples really write
what's in the New Testament or author it
you know these are questions that to
this day people have not um you know
debates that haven't settled do you have
such a thing with Islam does anyone
doubt the Quran came from the prophet
history upon him did anyone doubt that
the Quran has been preserved is anybody
doubt that the prophet claimed that
there's one God worthy of worship and
that he's just a prophet and messenger
nobody dealt this it is so clear
islamically and it came just I think 600
years after Jesus you know it survived
for 1400 years
yeah and and in that crucial time this
the companions really work to preserve
the religion in that crucial time the
disciples there weren't many of them and
there had many different forces working
against them so they they had trouble
preserving that obviously so it really
comes down to
which is better preserved as a source
because if you're going to use the
source it has to at least be
authoritative it has to have some kind
of authority if I would narrate an event
that I never witnessed why would you
believe me
as opposed to someone who was there and
you know what's there so but I do want
to ask you
uh you mentioned the Jesus thing so what
could you pinpoint what about the Jesus
thing is holding you back
I the biggest thing for me is just I've
believed so deeply in
Jesus from at least what I've been told
from family and going to church and all
it has been it was such a big aspect to
my childhood for sure uh and that's the
last little thing that it's it's funny I
I don't pray in Jesus name
but yet that little aspect is the one
thing that still kind of hold me back is
like not seeing him as as God or
whatever you to call it like yeah
actually speaking of that the Trinity do
you have any any helpful info about the
Trinity because that like I know there's
like the whole obviously God the father
Jesus Son and there's the Holy Spirit
but uh do you know how do you have any
understanding of where that originated
or how that originated yeah absolutely
so when you look at the earliest belief
like Paul himself he would write things
like the the head of woman is a man the
head of man is Christ and the head of
Christ is God you know the father so in
the same way that Christ is an authority
over human beings the father is an
authority over Christ so this belief is
what they call subordinationism they
believe that the sun is subordinate to
the Father the father is greater than
the son even though the sun is still God
it wasn't until 300 years later that
people got together and they said no the
sun is equal to the father he's Eternal
like the father and the Holy Spirit is
equal and internal like the Son and the
father this came 300 years later because
they were given a basic framework the
father is God that Jesus Jesus is god
um in somehow the Holy Spirit also
slipped him as being God and now they
had to make it work so in the Council of
nicaea they decided on the Nicene Creed
of Trinity co-equal co-eternal persons
that it came 300 years later Jesus never
mentioned it in all of the Bible 300
years later Jesus literally literally
the year 325 and Jesus I think peace be
upon him uh was crucified or was raised
to heaven in the year 33.
um last thing I want to mention on this
is
um when a young Jewish man came to Jesus
and asked him what is the most important
commandment he said hear o Israel your
Lord God is one he doesn't resemble
anything and the rest of it is he
doesn't resemble anything in the sky
anything on the earth or anything in the
sea why didn't he say hero Israel your
lord is three persons and one God the
Trinity co-equal Eternal like he didn't
explain that and Jews at the time they
understood it as there's one God just
the same way Muslims understand it so
why would he play this game of
mis-explaining what eternity is or not
just tell them what it is if you
believed it
geez well and a lot of research yeah bro
I just want to add something to romy's
point that Allah God will never give us
Revelation that's not clear
it's only the trick of the devil shaytan
to try to confuse us to try to twisting
to try to misrepresent things or
mistranslate things but Allah is always
going to be clear with us that's one
thing that is like a fundamental belief
it's it's in what we call our fitra like
our innate belief in our in a
predisposition that
God will never try to misguide us
willy-nilly or try to confuse us or give
us something that is not what he reveals
to us
that's something I really like the issue
that I I've had in my own I guess
journey is just you look for for answers
and the more answers you find the more
questions you have and that that's been
something I've has annoyed me and I I
finally got to a point where I was like
okay that's just I guess how this is uh
but the thing with Islam at least how
I've seen example like uh Jewels like
the way it's like his life has been he's
already on a good path and living a good
life and like have principles and all
that but his mind he keeps going on
about how just better his his mind is
working how life is just so much better
has purpose and seeing how it's
transformed him seeing how his
transformed into Tate and then other
friends of mine that aren't on social
media that have have reverted as well
and seeing how it's changed their life
and they they like how it's it's so
clear and concise and they keep this is
literally a common thing just questions
I've had for years this it all makes
sense now so that is a huge aspect to or
one of the many aspects I would say
that's sort of bringing me more and more
towards Islam uh is all the people
they're like man this it's answered all
these questions I've had for years and
some of them have literally been like
they're probably 10 20 years older than
me but they've been Christians so by
just by the math alone they've been
person longer than I have but they found
the answers that I've been searching for
uh so that that's it's been a it's an
interesting path
bro you said that you are a logical guy
correct correct
and with logic uncertainty
would you say that you prefer a
certainty or you prefer doubt
oh yeah us as humans we love certainty
of course and you said that it's been
annoying that you you find one answer
and then it erases arises another
question
right yeah so
with their logic then it will be only
fitting for you to keep seeking the
answers so that you can reach certainty
instead of just accepting what you
already have because what you already
have
there is some hint of uncertainty
and if there is one hint of uncertainty
in this regard
imagine how it's bleeding into all other
aspects of your life
jeez
that's deep that's a short that's like a
clip right there jeez
man that is true yeah because you have
that one little uncertainty of then it's
going to bleed into how you operate in
your day-to-day life and just
relationships friendships Etc
how do you do one thing is how you do
everything bro 100 that was I was
literally just saying that in my mind
geez I mean bro you talking about Jewel
you're talking about Andrew
and bro they're already operating at a
very high level right I'm sure you
yourself you also operate at a very high
level so now to see two individuals who
are operating at a high level just like
you
and they accept Islam and it's giving
them
a completely new gear like it's like
you're talking about a car you're
shifting gears bro they just shifted
into a completely different gear
right and why do they do this because
they have certainty now
there's a difference this brother told
us this when we were doing umra after we
met you in UAE he said there's a
difference between believing something
and 99 percent
versus believing it 100
facts
yeah like the whole like your whole like
neurological like being completely
changes when you have that one percent
doubt you're completely different than
when you like your entire structure
neurologically changes when you have
that 100 certainty in something
like 98 to 99 is nothing bro there's
like barely any difference but the 99 to
100 is everything yeah yeah yeah I'm
sure you've experienced this before
where you're like like take two
situations that happen in your personal
life one where you're like I'm
absolutely gonna do this and the one
where you're like okay I'm gonna do my
best right yeah when you're like I'm
actually gonna do it it gets done when
you say I'm gonna do my best even if
you're sure you're gonna get it done
sometimes you just procrastinate or that
one percent becomes the majority later
on when you when you procrastinate a
little too long then you don't get it
done
yeah 100 they talk about like
freelancing thing we were talking about
earlier like the guys they just 100
they're like okay we see the lifestyle
Dylan has we see all the wins they're in
the freelancing campus I I 100 believe
this is gonna happen I just need to
follow the steps
not surprisingly they get results the
people that they're like
half and half out it takes them
noticeably longer to get that result so
yeah it's certainty is what we're all
after and yeah man bro you really you
messaged me with that you've gotten to
my bro and it's not even I don't know
it's trying to force you to become more
it's us just wanting the best for you
and then us inviting you to keep looking
for the answers
because it's a simple one I saw this
video with Tristan T and PVD and he was
saying that someone asked him when are
you going to become Muslim but what are
you going to choose to become Muslim or
something like this and then you say oh
the river or
uh or the convert yeah convert
he said that
it's not something you choose it's
something that happens to you which is
very crazy because when you look into
Islam and it they have certain points in
the Quran where Allah says that
people don't accept Islam because of us
someone is not going to convert a Reverb
because of us because of what we do
because of what we say
because it's not us who is guiding it's
it's God who is guiding it again
so if someone is going to come to Islam
someone's going to be Muslim
it's because God is guiding them to do
this so right I'm not saying that me
fired or Rami is uh going to make you
into Muslim nor are we trying to we're
just saying look you've brought up the
fact of logic you brought the whole
thing of certainty I think I brought
this up so why not you know why not look
for the answer so that you can reach
that 100 certainty and then see what's
waiting for you at the end of 100
certainty yeah bro and Allah says in the
Quran that if all of the people in the
earth gathered around and they tried to
misguide you but Allah intends to guide
you none of them can misguide you bro
and if all the people in the in the
earth they try to guide you they try to
bring you on Dean but Allah doesn't will
for you to get guided you're not going
to get guided bro it's very simple so
when we were in in you know Dubai and we
were all eating together and you know we
were asking these questions like do you
believe in this does this and then you
were like yes and then we're like okay
then you're basically Muslim you have
all the beliefs necessary to be a Muslim
we didn't follow that up with okay are
you ready no no because as Tristan said
it's like on that Journey where you do
more research that you inevitably are
guided to Islam we ask you these
questions so you have something to think
about and something's marinating in your
mind when we're not with you that you're
like okay damn if I really do believe in
all these things then am I Muslim if I
if I don't believe in this then am I
Christian it's it's not so we can make
that step for you but it's to have these
open Loops of communication
subconsciously in your mind for you to
reflect on later and these things human
beings that that thing that we were
talking about how you do one thing is
how you do everything else if we have
doubts in our mind or contradictions or
hypocrisies and how we operate then they
kind of bleed into other avenues of our
life they bring on other thought
patterns subconscious limiting beliefs
and it quite literally plagues you and
then people have like these big crises
and things like that but if we as men
can
in a way just practice what we preach
know ourself have a level of
self-awareness I think everybody would
be confronting these things asking these
questions and connecting these thoughts
faster it's only the people that kind of
like to have their eyes closed and they
pretend that okay you know what there's
number one I'm gonna live till I'm 70 80
90. you know I have this guaranteed I
guess perception of how my life is going
to look like and I have all these goals
I want to make all this money I'm gonna
get married and have this but it's like
by whose authority like who guaranteed
we're gonna get that far what only
matters is what you do with the time
that you're given and the time that
you're given is not guaranteed
yeah because because you're logical you
have a good head on your shoulders so
may God continue to increase you in that
regard I mean and you have to see in the
manner that
you can choose
to just look for the answers and see
what's there logically or you can choose
to be emotional and close off and stay
where you are because you want to stay
with some belief that you've had for the
rest of your for your entire life that
was what your parents are with your
family which you've been doing ever
since you were a kid
so it's it's two choices you choose the
logical approach you choose the
emotional approach if you say you're a
Christian and this is not just to you
brother just every single question
if you are 100 about it and you really
want to know the answers and you know
that Christianity is it is 100 the truth
okay
logically look for all the answers
and if at the end
that's the answer then that's the answer
but if at the end you find something
completely different
or you have to be ready to accept that
because if not then now you've chosen to
be
you're no longer ignorant now you're
choosing to be arrogant
because you know the truth you know oh
this is actually the truth
but I'm actually going to stick with
this because it just it feels better and
this is what I've been doing for my
entire life
you see what I'm saying
yeah the way you framed that I liked it
as well because it is if you're oh yeah
I'm just this is how I've always been
that is a very emotional thing
especially if you start understanding
from a logical standpoint okay that's
not true that's not true this is more
concise and you don't you don't question
it instead no no no I'm not going to
look at that this is what I've always
there's always what I believe that that
is a pretty emotional thing yeah I mean
bro when we met Jewel did he not tell us
time and time and again how he was not
born rich
you know I'm sure in the real world you
guys always preach about how there's no
victim mentality bro it doesn't matter
how much money you were born with or if
your parents were poor or anything like
that what matters more is what you do
with your life so all these victim
mentalities or constraints that I guess
had us where we were once upon a time
that's fine that's No One's Gonna
dissolve that from any you know
responsibility but it matters more what
you do now going forward yeah 100
percent
so I should I'm curious how much of the
Quran have you read
I I mean I haven't Quantified it or
anything I just it's one of those things
I've got in my room in there and I'll
just right before bed or sometimes be
randomly during the day or right in the
morning I'll just open up and start
reading I still need to get the Hadith I
need to get that I'm actually I'm going
to write that down I'll get it tomorrow
let's see
and this is it yeah I would say I would
say just read the Quran cover to cover
once and okay I think honestly it'll
give you all the answers you need and
and what Angel is just talking about
um about you know this is the way I
lived I don't want to change the way you
find that that was the response of a lot
of the people who were sent prophets and
Messengers the people would come and say
worship one God Alone abandon the idols
and the false gods and they would say do
you want us to turn away from the path
that our forefathers were on you'll want
us to basically abandon our forefathers
in their way it's the same thing here so
you're gonna find a lot of commonalities
in the Quran with your own experiences
in life and I really think that above
anything the three of us could say or
any Muslim the world could say Allah
speaking to you through the Quran is
really all that you need
okay well I'll I'll read it I'll start
at the very beginning and I'll just
start reading until I get to the end
then yeah that'd be great man and take
your time it's randomly doing it just
like I teach students don't just
randomly send DMS randomly do this like
you actually want to get a result you
have to 100 stick of the process start
with step one two three four five six
seven eight so I'm gonna get the Quran
tonight and I'll start reading at the
very beginning and I'll continue to the
end amazing moment amazing and I want
you I want you to understand too that
when you're looking for answers like
even let's say you became Muslim
all right let's just theoretically say
you became Muslim even then it doesn't
mean that you close off
that's a big misconceptions people think
that once they start following a
religion their clothes off to everything
no no
in complete Essence it's completely
different like Allah tells us to to read
for ourselves find the answers for us so
it's like even as a Muslim I still
look at everything around me I still am
very open because I'm I'm a secret of
the truth I want to know the truth
because why because it gives me
certainty and the certainty allows me to
function and operate at a completely
different level so with this being said
you know I've had people come to me and
they're talking to me about
Zoroastrianism they're talking maybe
talking to me about Sikhism they're
talking about Hinduism they're talking
with you about Jenny's or about devoism
about Buddhism about other stuff and I
would never cut them off nor would I
ever try to shut them up
because I like hearing everything and I
like looking into things myself I like
seeing the answers for myself
so remember if if you truly want that
certainty if you want that logic
then I just recommend you just look for
the answers don't stop don't don't say
ah you know what another question is
going to come bro
if another question comes up
don't stop if you're in the business
right if you're in a business you've
made x amount of money
and now a problem comes up that you need
to have a solution for in order to keep
progressing and making more money within
the business and scaling it would you
stop there
oh no I'll keep searching keep growing
keep scaling yeah exactly so this is no
different
yeah and matter of fact it's more
important because all that money that
you make it's like you're not taking
that anywhere when you die sure you can
leave it for your can of course but
imagine the afterlife
eternity not just one or two years three
years no but eternity bro and all that's
necessary is for you to do the inner
work which seems easy
and I guess some people might consider
it simple but these are the deep dark
questions that many people don't ask
themselves a lot of them distract
themselves from asking these questions
by compensating with overworking or some
substance or some addiction or something
like that yeah
foreign
honestly it's been a pleasure Dylan
thank you so much I want to give you the
floor before we end off obviously if
there's any final words you want to say
to the viewers
no I I mean thank you for taking the
time to bring me on you guys have been
super super awesome uh and yeah for
anybody that's watching this just as
we've learned today stay on the path
keep asking questions and stay positive
be a beacon of positivity especially in
today's world where everybody wants you
to be distracted by all this other
nonsense and be negative or if you turn
on the TV and you start like oh yeah the
world's ending no just stay positive and
focus on building some kind of skill set
that you can monetize especially online
obviously because nobody else is going
to take care of you you especially if
you're a man you are in charge and
responsible if taking care of your
future kids your future wife and the
family around you nobody else is going
to do it for you you've got to do it and
as we've learned tonight
that little bit of Doubt is going and
uncertainty is just going to spoil your
life so may you may as well get some
certainty by one gaining a skill putting
in the work every single day and this is
actually I guess the last message a lot
of people they over stress themselves
and criticize themselves they think they
need to massively improve overnight and
instead I want you to reframe this in
your mind and just focus on getting like
just one or two percent better every day
like every morning whenever I wake up
late today I had a lot more to do I've
got a whiteboards like eight different
things and I did but on any given day
I've got like two main things that I
knock out so on your end it could be
literally doing some push-ups and then
after that whether you're in the real
world or not doesn't matter but doing
something that benefits you so if you're
wanting to make money you need to learn
a skill money's not some magical thing
you need to have an actual skill
something of value to offer other people
and I mean that's what I teach inside
the freelancing campus but you need to
have a very clear and concise idea of
what you want to accom published on the
day stop wasting days or days and days
of your life just half half and half out
going through the day mindlessly
consuming that like that's gonna lead to
destruction so just get a one percent
better every single day that would be my
final message
and bro thank you for coming on and
dropping all these gems and very thought
provoking nonetheless you've inspired me
a lot to go get it and we look forward
to hosting you again bro and you know
where to find us anytime thank you
brother of course some pleasure as all
ours thank you so much for joining us
it's been amazing inshallah we will
definitely do this again very soon and
with that being said
inshallah we'll see you guys on the next
one
all right all right